girlfriend keeps talking to guys when
i'm not around they've been together for
almost nine years now she's been going
out with her girlfriends when she comes
home she talks about the people they
meet as of late these have only been
guys she's always been super outgoing
and social and i love that about her
this guy's an idiot but lately she's
been giving out her number to these guys
i asked her about it when a guy kept
texting her that i didn't know she said
it was a guy she met in vegas why are
you permitting your girlfriend to go
down to las vegas guys what's the matter
with you seriously you know what happens
in vegas right i've been to vegas i'm
sure you've been to vegas you don't let
your girl go anywhere overnight like
vegas or new york city or any of those
girls trips anyway when she went to a
concert she talked about it and when i
asked her if she told him she was in a
relationship she said no why would that
matter after that conversation she's
been doing she's been kind of hiding her
phone from me i've always trusted her
and she's never given a reason not to am
i just in my head or should i ask her
about it